nicolas sarkozy donc est entré ce matin
il était 9 heures environ dans le bureau
des juges du pôle financier
les dépenses de sa campagne de 2012 sont
au coeur des interrogations que
savait-il donc du dépassement au bas mot
dit on quelques 19 millions d'euros sur
quoi selon vous où va déboucher son
audition bon d'abord il ya une réalité
vous employez à juste titre le terme
d'audition c'est lui il s'agit d'une
audition qui s'inscrit dans la suite
à vrai dire logique dans une suite
prévisible d'une instruction dans ce que
l'on a appelé la ferme igm alliance est
la conséquence et nicolas sarkozy vous
en souvenez a constamment indiqué et
sans d'ailleurs être un ce jour démenti
à aucun moment et a toujours indiqué
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas
personnellement cette société il a
toujours il l'a toujours dit là la
question par le tarissement des cons 3e
troisième élément à ce jour son
honnêteté et sa probité personnelle
on avait observé ne sont pas mises en
cause donc je crois que puisque vous
poser une question je vais peut-être
vous décevoir encore pour pourquoi vous
décevoir pourquoi je dis ça d'air parce
que c'est la stricte vérité c'est que je
crois qu'il faut le laisser la procédure
se poursuive
que la justice fasse son travail et
c'est très bien bon wind et savait par
un que sa campagne fut si
inflationnistes qui était au courant et
qui est responsable
selon vous à bien j'observe d'ailleurs
ce que votre affirmation qui et on va
tout à fait dans le sens de ce que je
pense mais enfin au delà de vous elle a
été confirmée par exemple par jean
françois copé qui a indiqué dans
l'audition qui est rendue publique
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui ce qui pose
toujours le problème du secret de
l'instruction en face à ces quelque
chose sur laquelle tout le monde
s'assoit sens à chaque personne et
indique que à aucun moment enfin là au
canon dans l'audition jean françois copé
dans ses déclarations et il n'est
indiqué que nicolas sarkozy était au
courant dont françois copé d'ailleurs
confirmée alors lui n'a pas été mis en
examen il à dire là je suis soulagé je
n'ai plus l'épée de damoclès au dessus
de ma tête est ce que vous croyez que
cette épée de damoclès change de tête ce
soir ou demain si l'audition se
poursuivre et sortent jamais je vous dis
il faut laisser la procédure se
poursuive encore une fois c'est ce qui
est se déroule cette audition elle était
attendue elle était logique c'est dans
le cas d'une procédure est que non mais
il faudra moins de 40 ans est très
serein oui ça va je les plains
aujourd'hui mais enfin il était ces
jours derniers totalement serein et
concentré sur la responsabilité qui est
la sienne vous vous êtes confiant ou
inquiets comme impressionner vos tracas
judiciaires
écoutez je pense que comme le disait un
cadre des républicains nouveau câble
disais quelque part trop c'est trop
côté jeux non moi je ne te dis pas
d'autre chose que la justice fasse son
travail trop c'est trop
non je dis pas ça je dis c'est ce qui
m'a été dit mais moi je vous dis que la
justice fasse son travail que le fast
sereinement et ce qu'elle décide
rassurera il saura t elle vient décide
c'est un délire de financement illégal
que de dépasser les plafonds de campagne
vous dites qu'il n'a pas été averti dans
le dossier ont dit que peut-être un
expert comptable avait prévu vous nous
avez pas entré dans le détail de la
comptabilité des campagnes électorales
puisque j'ai en moi même d'être un génie
comprend pas toujours tout vous savez
dans les dépenses qui sont évoqués si
j'ai bien compris il ya des dépenses de
train vimy tibre donnons deux meetings
très honnêtement il a fait à peu près en
gros
le même nom de meetings que son
principal concurrent qui était françois
hollande
je crois que françois hollande indique
35-37 meeting nicolas sarkzoy d'indiquer
45,46 jeu de cet ordre là le premier
élément deuxième élément il faut être un
nid père spécialiste un expert bon pour
savoir si telle dépense par exemple de
transport de train doit être imputée à
la campagne doit être imputée à la
famille politique
si il y à des dépenses globales qui ne
aussi concerner les élections les
attirer tout ceci est très compliqué ce
qui est sûr ce qui est certain c'est que
l'honnêteté et la probité de nicolas
sarkozy ne sont à aucun moment mis en
cause et mais finalement ne surprend pas
il met également en avant d'enfourner le
fait qu'il était président la république
et candidat donc président la public
très accaparé c'est une thèse que vous
dites mais également bien pas le temps
que j'ai fait ça je sais ce que j'ai
vécu moi-même j'ai été candidat tête de
liste aux élections européennes sur
trois régions l'auvergne ma région la
région centre limousin et un budget de
campagne très honnêtement et je moi je
me préoccupais pas des dépenses vous
préoccupez effectivement des recettes et
à la fin de la campagne j'ai réunis en
équipes le trésorier judee samarie n'y a
pas de souci tu es tu es tu es sûr que
tout est dans les clous oui oui et puis
voilà on paraphe un document très
honnêtement j'imagine que quand on est
chef de l'état et candidat en même temps
ceci est démultipliée
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence vous
l'approuvez oui est ce que vous demandez
par exemple certains de vos amis par
exemple au sénat de droite aujourd'hui
d'aller plus vite dans la
constitutionnalisation de l'état
d'urgence avec la dèche et en ma
conviction c'est que le sénat a un rôle
très important à jouer et série permet
d'être au sénat de rappeler quelle est
la nature et qu'elle doit être
l'objectif qu'elle doit tête sont elles
sont précisément sans son rôle sa
responsabilité plus quand il roule
d'ailleurs la responsabilité c'est
précisément d'écrire un texte ou
invoquer la déchéance et qu'ils
reprennent ce qui avait été déclaré
d'ailleurs au mois de novembre par le
chef de l'état une solution compris pour
le compromis pour aller vite
écouter réellement le chef de l'état à
l'écouté du chef de l'état et bien malin
celui qui comprend très exactement le
fil de sa pensée
parce que soit c'est très compliqué soit
ça serait très ficelles au choix
peut-être est-ce d'ailleurs les deux
complexes et ficelles parce que la
réalité c'est qu'il ya eu cinq ou six
positions différentes
depuis le 16 novembre reconnaissez que
c'est pas d'une clarté aveuglante et
peut-être ficelles ficelles enfin pardon
à force de vouloir trop finasser il
arrive qu'on se ramasse et c'est le
péché de l'état peut être voulez tendre
un piège à l'opposition moyennant quoi
ça s'est refermé sur ce qui n'est pas
très glorieux
ce n'est pas très grand mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que oui moi
j'appartiens à ces parlementaires qui
sommes favorables à la déchéance de
nationalité
et ce n'est pas parce que c'est françois
hollande qui l'a promu ou qu'il a
rappelé ou qu'il a repris exactement
et bien c'est pas parce que c'est lui
qu'on doit automatiquement un condamné
ce qui compte un moment donné c'est
qu'il faut faire pour être à l'heure à
la société j'en viens de vous dire à
fissel fils l ennemi le patron des
sénateurs socialistes didier guillaume à
vire t aujourd'hui les victimes des
attentats ne peuvent pas être les otages
de la primaire des républicains est là
il a raison de viser donc ce que vous
évoquez là
utiliser ceux qui sont opposés à la gpe
françois fillon non ce sont des propos
injurieux
ce sont des propos injurieux parce que
sur un sujet aussi grave qui touche à
l'intérêt général qui concerne la
protection de nos concitoyens qui
relèvent de la sécurité collective nous
présenter ainsi et le réduire à des
compétitions des émulations électorale
c'est indigne
donc je dis ce sont des propos âge
les candidats à la primaire
ils ont comme préoccupation leur avenir
dans cette campagne pour la primaire
nicolas sarkozy sa responsabilité est
totalement différente
elle est deux fois différente la
première c'est que et pèse sur lui la
responsabilité de notre famille
politique
je vous rappelle que il a il n'est pas
là par le fruit du hasard
ça peut dépérit n'est pas là par
l'opération du service fait même si
celui ci peut aider il est là parce
qu'il a été élu c'est pas une
auto-proclamation il est là parce qu'il
a été élu élu très largement puisque il
a été élu avec le double de voix de
celui qui était son concurrent le plus
direct le doubs c'est vous dire comme le
succès a été large et donc il a sur ses
épaules et donc sa responsabilité sur
les épaules c'est celle de l'ensemble de
notre famille qui était fracturée et il
a réussi
il a mis autour de la table tous ceux
qui voulaient la renverser c'est vrai
que ça c'est le premier élément est
deuxième élément concernant le projet
wii
pardonnez moi il dit quelque chose qui
me paraît de bon sens c'est que une
famille politique qui n'a pas un projet
collectif
franchement il faut qu'elle renonce donc
lui sa responsabilité alors c'est
peut-être pas son bénéfice personnel
alors j'espère certainement pour la
cause collective et de mettre sur la
table c'est de mettre sur la table un
projet qui soit un projet collectif
verra sa seule préoccupation c'est le
rassemblement on peut se demander en
même temps à quoi ça sert le parti quand
il ya des primaires et que chacun fait
son projet dans son coin et qu'alain
juppé ne dit pas je vais aller piocher
dans le corpus du parti ce qui a été
préparé quand les ce qui confère vendée
démarche individuelle et personnelle
c'est leur droit mais c'est un choix du
passé à l'abri c'est leur choix c'est
leur responsabilité nous autour de
nicolas sarkozy nous avons une
préoccupation collective et c'est vrai
que nous voulons mettre sur la table un
projet qui est un projet fort et
peut-être reviendra-t-on un projet fort
et ce projet fort si des candidats
veulent le leuy rajouter des choses
qu'ils le fassent ils veulent en
retrancher c'est naturellement leurs
droits mais nous au tour de nicolas
sarkozy a raison de le dire c'est de ne
pas penser aujourd'hui exclusivement
lui mais de penser à l'intérêt collectif
scène et je pense que ce week-end c'est
pour ça que je pense que c'était une
réunion et une rencontre utile
je pense que ce week-end ça en a été la
démonstration et en même temps c'est
vrai qu'on a un peu l'impression qu'il
est affaibli
on se dit il ya des candidats aux
primaires qui commencent à s'aligner
parce que là on en a plusieurs projets
on a un nouveau candidat puis dimanche
soir jean françois copé de nouveaux
projets qui vont arriver c'est difficile
comme vous lâcher ce qui là est ce que
ce n'était pas une erreur de revenir à
la tête du parti
alors je pars c'est leur case là j'aurai
beaucoup de choses à dire pardon parce
que vous évoquez beaucoup tél
premièrement oui vous avez la raison sur
un point la question de son retour de
son engagement à la tête de notre
famille politique c'est une vraie
question je fais partie de ceux qui ont
ardemment milité peut-être pas
d'ailleurs dans l'intérêt personnel de
nicolas sarkozy
mais notre famille qui porte des valeurs
qui affiche des convictions qui a des
idées à défendre était pardon de lire en
voie de déstructuration peut-être même
d'ailleurs de disparition et s'ils ne
s'étaient pas engagés
s'il n'avait pas construire reconstruire
cette famille politique
sans doute serait il serait ton
aujourd'hui dans une toute autre
hypothèse un colloque l'ordre pour
l'élection présidentielle pas de doutes
sur le retour dans la thèse du par bien
sûr à 2015 a été l'année de la
reconstruction et du rassemblement et
ça doit être l'année de l'authenticité
et de la clarté dans les choix
et bien c'est précisément le chemin et
que nous que nous empruntons aujourd'hui
alors deuxième point si vous le
permettez pas ce que vous dites est ce
que t'as pas affaibli moi je viens je
reviens sur ce point voilà nicolas
sarkozy qui écrit un livre dont on sait
ce soir d'ailleurs que il tangente les
135 me exemplaires c'est un énorme
succès d'ailleurs regardez le traitement
particulier qui réservait à nicolas
sarkozy puisque c'est le seul auteur je
connaisse pour lequel on on fait un
sondage auprès des français pour savoir
s'il voudrait lâcheté et la tue 10 %
répondent oui vient à certains
certainement un problème certain mais
pas vous qui ont dit
il n'y a que 10 % c'est en fait
considérable c'est du presque du jamais
vu à ce point la borne est faite au
premier et les moyens sont récemment
recoins aussi pourquoi ça prouve qu'il
ya une attente et qu'il est aussi
porteur d'espoir et que l'on attendait
aussi sa part de vérité parce que ce
souvenir
c'est un exercice de vérité c'est une
démonstration ci d'humilité donc on ne
renie rien de regrets volonté de
simplicité on y suit un de ses amis il
n'y a pas de nom c'est savez le blabla
que j'ai entendue dès les années 2012
sur le thème art il faudrait qu'il fasse
son bilan son ne doit primer le devoir
d'inventaire et à l'époque je disais
écoutez si on a un qui doit le faire ce
sera lui
vous savez qu'il ya un mécanisme
européen qui fait qu'on peut mettre des
réfugiés un peu partout en europe dans
tous les pays d'oc et un gala merkel
elle a reçu près d'un million françois
hollande visiblement maintenant serait
contre ce mécanisme en tout cas sur nos
temps manuel valls la peau la politique
française a changé en cette matière
alors qu'ils étaient pour en septembre
oui là vous salue et peut-être l'action
d'abord la commission européenne vous
connaissez vous êtes un spécial ces
questions la commission européenne avait
annoncé qu'ils auraient samson 160000
relocalisation quelque sorte
vous savez comme il y en a eu sur les
160 milles aller des 8 joueurs 561 sur
160 mille cinq cent soixante et il ya eu
joueurs peut-être c'est peut-être un
petit peu plus aujourd'hui 616 comme que
je voulais d'ordures mais je veux dire
que la commission que l'europe là dessus
ça ne marche pas deuxième élément oui
vous avez raison la politique française
c'est une politique de gribouille sur ce
sujet on y comprend strictement rien
c'est comme elle c'est comme c'est comme
pour la déchéance de national la
nationalité on a des affirmations d'un
côté qui sont démenties le lendemain si
aujourd'hui un français qui comprend
qu'il est la politique menée par notre
gouvernement en matière d'immigration il
est très fort en tout cas il faut le
faire venir pour l'inviter faire
beaucoup de choses parce que c'est
rigoureusement en avance sur la
réparation des migrants est ce que vous
êtes contre comme manuel valls donc d'un
système permanent de répartition comme
le veulent à l'europe
je dis une chose simple c'est que
concernant notre pays
bien sûr il faut lutter contre les
filières premiers éléments deuxième
élément bien sûr il faut lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine
je vous rappelle qu'à l'échelon européen
l'année dernière
en enfin le dernier chiffre connu c'est
2014 c'est une autre d'autres dimensions
il y a eu 460 mille décisions de
reconduite dans 421 milles décisions de
reconduite
il y en a cent soixante mille seulement
qui ont été appliquées
donc première politique française parce
que petit français c'est aussi la
politique européenne donc un lutter
contre les filières deux bien sûr lutter
contre l'immigration illégale
on ne vient pas en europe et on ne vient
pas en france si on
et pas autorisés si on vient sans y être
autorisées on a vocation à être
reconduit dans son pays d'origine
a fortiori quand ce ne sont pas des
vrais demandeurs d'asile le vice
président de la commission européenne ce
n'est pas moi à donner c'est loin et
troisièmement je vous le dis je le dis
aussi très calmement je suis très
sérieusement je lis très pondéré mans il
faut aussi dans notre pays faire
diminuer l'immigration légale
nous ne sommes pas l'allemagne
l'allemagne un taux de natalité qui est
de 20 37 c'est hier que le
renouvellement des générations n'est pas
assurée l'allemagne va avoir une pénurie
d'emploi avant 2020 qui touchera un
million huit cent mille postes ce n'est
pas le cas dans notre pays donc les
besoins de l'allemagne ne sont pas les
mêmes
tout ceci pour dire quoi c'est qu'à
titre personnel en matière de
construction européenne je ne suis pas
pour que le système qui permet un
étranger arrivant sur un pays du
européens puissent se promener dans
toute l'europe sous prétexte qu'il a eu
un visa donc je suis pour que chaque
pays décide d'accueillir qui il souhaite
quels sont ses besoins
quelles sont ses volontés mais pas que
cela donne automatiquement et
mécaniquement le droit de se pencher à
temps et ça si on va y revenir sur
schengen 2 oui oui mais ça va pas tarir
quoi que ce soit écouté chaignat même si
vous réécrire schengen schengen pour
rappeler c'est un traité signé en 1985
qui permet un citoyen pénétrant dans le
territoire schengen d'aller sur la
totalité des autres territoires avec un
titre donc légal
le seul problème schengen et je
comprends pas pourquoi personne
franchement de leur appel c'est que
schengen ça a été signé en 1985 à cinq
pays
nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 26 22 pays
européens
enfin deux pays membres de l'union
européenne et quatre à l'extérieur la
norvège la suède la suisse est ainsi tu
dois donc un traité signé à 5 pardon
s'il est pas vécu de la même manière
quand tout d'un coup il doit s'appliquer
à 26 et nous assistons effectivement
vous réglez de schengen lafayette
il va fort quand même laurent wauquiez
il dit même aussi qu'il faut durcir le
droit à l'acquisition de la nationalité
française et dit c'est l'auberge
espagnole vous partager son art mais
alors il ya plusieurs sujets première le
sujet venez vous partager l'avis de
laurent wauquiez qui a dû vous survivrez
pas sur l'accès nationalité je pense
exactement et joue d'ailleurs nous
avions diminué les conditions d'accès à
la nationalité
le gouvernement l'a aussi expliquer une
politique très ferme l'acquisition à
nationalité augmente
il a une politique très ferme les
demandes d'asile augmentent de 22 % et
donc non celle inverse de ce que fait ce
que dit le gouvernement ce qu'il fait
c'est le contraire de ce qu'il dit est
donc l'acquisition à nationalité oui
bien sûr il faut revoir les conditions
et les critères d'accès il faut revoir
les conditions et critères du
regroupement familial
il faut que le temps pour bénéficier du
roman familial soit augmentée il faut
revoir les possibilités comme ça se fait
dans un certain nombre de pays la france
2 hélas ce ne serait pas pionnière sur
ce sujet et comme ça se fait un certain
nombre de pays il faut revoir les
conditions d'accès à l'ensemble des
prestations sociales
si un travailleur est en situation
légale sur notre sur notre territoire et
contribuer comme tous les citoyens
français la même manière par ses
cotisations sociales fiscales et
instituts il doit naturellement avoir
les mêmes droits
naturellement simplement signer
contribue pas et bien avant d'avoir
accès aux prestations sociales
il faut effectivement qu' un certain
délai